- Before I went to college, I
wish I had hugged my parents
and ate a lot more of
their home cooked meals
because you're gonna get
tired of ramen pretty quick.
- First off, don't worry about
any of the high school drama
and any of the guys in your
high school, any of those people
because they're gonna be
irrelevant in about two months.
- The one thing I wish I would have done
in between high school and college
would definitely be find internships,
at least one summer internship
or just internships at all.
Start the free stuff now
so that once you leave college,
you've already built your ground
and most jobs actually want
to hire you afterwards.
- I'm from Hawaii,
and something that I
really wish I did more of
before I went to college
was go to the beach.
I went to school in Ohio,
in middle of nowhere Ohio,
and so, obviously there are no beaches
and the closest body of
water was the Ohio River
so that's not the best to swim in.
- Learn about sex and drugs
because there's a lot of that in college
and it's better to be educated.
That way, you know what
you're getting yourself into.
You're not doing too much too fast.
- Remember to document everything.
Take as many pictures with
your friends as possible.
- Get that wardrobe right.
You gotta go in, you
gotta stunt on everyone,
you gotta be looking good,
so just kind of like
revitalize that whole wardrobe.
- Learn some respect for deadlines.
That shit's gonna get you.
If you don't get it,
they're gonna smack you against the wall.
Do that and learn how to cook.
- You should thank your teachers.
You should also hang out with your friends
as much as possible.
It's the last summer you're
gonna be able to do it.
- Somehow, remember that you
signed off on a student loan
'cause you're gonna forget
and then, five years later,
you're gonna get something in the mail
that says you signed a
student loan for like $5000.
Totally not speaking
from personal experience.
- Read a book that you
actually want to read for fun
because I don't think you're gonna
want to read a book for fun
for the next four years
until college is over.
- My last summer before
college, I definitely regret
not actually just chilling.
I was just doing too much
and preparing for college.
And then once it starts, that's it.
You go through your four years,
and then it's like you're in
the workforce and that's that.
- Before I went to college,
I worked at my summer camp,
my sleep away summer camp,
and I didn't pack anything.
And my mom graciously packed
everything I could have
ever needed for me,
so my advice is to go get things
you need for college for yourself
so that when you get there,
you know what you have.
- During my last summer before college,
I wish I would have
threw a graduation party.
I'm 25 and I never had a big party that
celebrated me and my accomplishments,
so that would have been dope.
- Take risks.
Put yourself in uncomfortable situations.
Don't do what everyone's telling you to do
'cause at least in my life,
that's when I found the
most interesting things
and kind of discovered who I was.
- Don't drink Jager.